I'm about to continuing in Al Wajeez
in the book of fasting
the chapter regarding the days
in which the prophet
prohibited a person fast.
The first
set of days that the author mentions is
the two days of Eid. So, the first of
Shawwal and the 10th of
of Dhul-Hijjah.
The second are
Tashreeq, the days of Tashreeq. We said
those days are which days of which
month?
Ayyam al-Tashreeq.
11, 12, 13 of
Dhul-Hijjah, very good.
And
the third
that the author mentions here
is Yawm al-Jumu'. We're starting to
notice a pattern here.
Right?
The two days of Eid.
Those are yearly
yearly
holidays, if you will, or commemorative
days.
And then the second are the days of
Tashreeq, which are an extension of a
holiday.
The third now that he mentions is the
day of Jumu' alone, by itself,
which is a type of weekly holiday, isn't
it? It's a recurring
event, it's a recurring mass right of
Islam,
but it recurs every week rather than
every year.
And so
on the day of Jumu',
a person is permitted to fast
under the condition that they do not
fast that day alone.
To fast the day of Jumu' and to choose
the day of Jumu'
as a solitary day to fast is prohibited.
And when we speak about choosing a
solitary day to fast, etc., we're
speaking about siyam al-tatawwu', the
optional fasting.
These rules do not apply to obligatory
fasting except for the days of Eid.
Except for the days of Eid
and in the opinion of the majority, the
days of al-Tashreeq as well.
Right?
However, the day of Jumu', if a person
were to single out the day of Jumu'
for fasting, but it is an obligatory
fast.
Right? Not just make up days from
Ramadan,
but an obligatory fast such as
a kaffarah,
such as
something of that sort, then in this
case
fasting the day of Jumu' would be
permissible. And this is very similar
to the prohibitions on times
in which a person is prohibited from
praying.
It's not
any prayer.
It is optional prayer during these
particular times.
But
obligatory prayer,
all of the scholars agree that these
times of prohibition do not apply to
obligatory
prayer. You know, we have
one of the most dangerous things
is having
a part
an incomplete part of knowledge.
This is dangerous. It's an It's
like
having a gun, a loaded gun with the
safety off, with your finger on the
trigger, pointing it at people, or
pointing it at yourself. It's dangerous.
Right?
Because you think that the gun is safe,
but it's not.
A part or incomplete knowledge is
dangerous in that same way.
A person thinks that they have the whole
picture,
but really they're missing a part.
So, for instance,
many people have heard.
Many people have heard. And now I'm
speaking from experience that I actually
thought this as well before I started
studying.
And that is that
how many of us have heard that it is
prohibited to pray
after the sun rises
until it is
high after Fajr, right? Until it's above
the horizon. And the same thing for
after Asr.
Many people, you would be surprised, or
maybe you wouldn't,
the amount of people that
would wake up
at Fajr,
at that time,
and not pray Fajr, and wait until the
sun rises fully and completely to make
Fajr.
Right? So, they'll sit there and watch
the sun
as the time of Fajr passes,
as the sun climbs in the sky,
they say, "Nope, can't pray now. The sun
is rising."
This is not at all what the prophet
intended.
This applies to optional prayer.
And it doesn't even apply to all
optional prayer. Right? As we will
learn, in sha Allah.
very specific types of optional
prayer. And the same thing goes with
fasting. These days which are prohibited
to fast
is a person just randomly choosing this
particular day to single out in fasting
in an optional fast.
And this is important. Why is it
important? Well, a person could fast the
entire day and their fast be
fast be invalid.
Does a good intention
cover for that lack of knowledge in this
kind of instance? No, it does not. You
have to learn before you do something.
That is the danger.
The overarching danger that we face is
this common misconception that as long
as my intention is pure,
I can just, you know,
do things.
And even if I'm wrong,
it's okay.
That's not how it works.
It's not how the physical world works,
and that's not how the Quran and Sunnah
works. If you have access to knowledge
and you fail to obtain that knowledge
before approaching Allah and worshipping
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
if that fails, it fails.
Good deeds do not make up for the good
intentions do not make up for those
kinds of mistakes. And so, fasting the
day of Jumu' munfaridan,
on its own.
Right?
Fasting the day of Jumu' as a solitary
day.
[Silence]
So,
he mentions the narration of Abu
Hurairah
who states that I heard the prophet
say,
"None of you is to fast on the day of
Jumu'
except that he is to fast a day before
it or a day after it."
So, either a person fasts Thursday and
Friday,
or he fasts Friday and Saturday.
Now, of course, the name
of the
book is Al Wajeez, the the concise or
the abridged book, right?
And
because of that, he doesn't mention all
of the evidences for any particular
issue. But there is another narration
in which the prophet
said,
spoke to one of his wives, she was
fasting,
and it was
Jumu'.
And so, he asked her, now she had
Imagine, she had already begun fasting
on the day of Jumu'.
He asked her,
"Did you fast yesterday?"
She said, "No."
He said, "Are you going to fast
tomorrow?"
She said, "No."
He said,
and he told her to break her fast.
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
And he prohibited her from fasting
Friday alone. Now, that narration
is not as powerful as the one we just
heard, which is why the author chose
this one
because of one reason, and that is the
audience.
In that narration, it's just one, his
wife.
In this narration,
he is speaking to the Muslimin in
general. He says,
right?
But, both narrations mean the same
thing, and that is that the day of
Jumu' is not to be fasted, it's not to
be observed in fasting on its own
without a day before or a day after.
And the same rule applies for the day of
Saturday,
which is the next one that the author
mentions.
Saturday
alone.
So, not fasting
Friday or not fasting Sunday with it.
[Silence]
He narrates that his
sister, Asma,
she narrates that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam said, "None of you is to
fast on the day of Saturday
except
for an obligatory fast. None of you is
to fast on Saturday,
a fast that is not obligatory.
And if you don't even have anything to
eat,
then
and all you had were the leaves of a
tree, then
or a stick from a tree, a twig from a
tree, or a branch, then take it and chew
it so as to ensure that your fast is
broken,
not even be associated with fasting on
Saturday,
a day that is not obligatory.
Now,
where did he get, the author,
where did he get from this narration
that
you are not to fast Saturday by itself?
The narration that he quotes
is not what he said in the
in his commentary.
The author in his commentary said,
"Saturday on its own." So, he gave it
the same rule as Friday.
But, then the narration,
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
says, "Do not fast Saturday unless it's
obligatory."
So, how did the author come to that?
Well,
he came to that
because of the previous narration.
Right? If a person is fasting on Friday
and fasts on Saturday because of Friday,
that is not an obligatory fast. Some
scholars have viewed that as an
obligatory fast, but it is not.
It is still an optional fast.
likewise,
there are other instances that we will
get into, other instances in the Sunnah,
in which
exceptions are shown to this general
rule.
But, in general,
people,
you know, in mass are not usually the
the way of the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam in teaching people
is he does not teach the general
audience exceptions to rules.
He teaches them general rules.
Right?
Exceptions to rules,
he teaches to
either those who come asking about them,
those to whom the
exceptions apply,
or to those who are,
you know,
his his
his most knowledgeable companions, those
who understand how to balance exceptions
and rules.
But, the general masses of people,
usually people, they are on one of two
modes, either yes or no, black or white,
right? Right or wrong,
haram or halal, wajib or right? They
can't balance both. And so, you won't
find often in the Sunnah that the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
teaches the general audience exceptions
to a rule.
He'll usually just teach them what?
The general for instance,
backbiting, backbiting your Muslim
brother.
Is it absolutely impermissible, no
matter what the situation?
Of course not. There are instances in
which it's obligatory.
But, he never taught something that
on the minbar. Why? Because
the general masses of people,
they either have
yes or no. They have two gears,
right? They have forward or reverse.
That's all they got.
And so, if you teach them
"Backbiting is haram,
except
one instance or two instances or three
instances." Everybody who wants to
backbite someone is going to feel like
that applies to them. They're special.
That's They're the
Right? How many times have
you read, for instance, in a a book of
fatawa where a scholar will say, "This
is permissible
under the condition of" and the listener
shut off as soon as he heard the word
permissible, that's it. The rest of it,
he ignored it.
He didn't even hear the rest of "under
the condition" or "provided" or right?
It's just how people are, and that and
that's not just, you know, Muslims with
their religion, that's
anyone who is not skilled in a field,
any field.
Details come with scholarship in any
field, any field.
Right? Even in eating.
Eating,
a chef has a much more
refined palate and can taste things
that a regular person can't taste, they
can't appreciate it. Right? They can eat
french fries drenched in ketchup and it
tastes fine to them. Right? Where that
would be disgusting to a chef who was
spending all day making these
refined meals. Why? Because this person
is advanced in his field. Anyone who
advances in their field,
they start to appreciate detail.
But, the general people,
they don't
appreciate detail naturally. They have
to learn that. And so, the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam, he
understands this. So, he didn't teach
details in a mass scale. He taught that
to his closest companions, the most
knowledgeable, or someone who would come
and this detail applies to them
in that specific instance.
[Silence]
Alaykum salaam.
Isha tonight is at 8:30.
Okay, so Isha tonight,
starting tonight is at 8:30.